in early April I began to warn about the
damage extended lockdowns would have on
America and since then we've experienced
millions of job losses added trillions
to our debt and experienced terrible
riots but one of the first things that
happen and the worst things that
happened was how much learning was lost
by our kids by being locked out of their
classrooms so with the Trump Recovery
fully underway Democrats are shifting
back to their default position shut the
economy down yes that's where they are
now and that includes of course our
schools now they cite the rising kovat
infection rates in certain states to
sell their latest panic porn the United
States and free fall from the
coronavirus a top infectious disease
doctor is warning today and right now as
we speak the number of daily cases is
double what it was just some months ago
take that and double what it was just a
month ago what about the mortality rate
well when people say follow the science
take it with a grain of salt because
science by its very nature is always
evolving as our understanding of the
world around us
improves now despite this it's never
difficult to find an expert who will try
to scare you into giving up your freedom
some of these states were the number of
cases is in the thousands per day it's
absolutely impossible to do contact
tracing and isolation and Quarantine at
those numbers in those areas you're
gonna have to be moving back to everyone
shelter in place everyone stay home if
you really want to get this under
control did you hear it going back to
shelter in place now you sense don't you
that this is where the Democrats are
going to be heading and that President
Trump he they're gonna say is
endangering America by insisting that we
stay open in other words we must close
down for the National good now this is a
scorched-earth approach to this virus
and one that we already know doesn't
really work now most states did issue
stay at home orders with only essential
business
is open no.1 guess what we discovered
the virus is still out there when people
start moving about again well yes people
get sick
some will tragically die especially
those who are vulnerable people who are
elderly struggle with diabetes or
autoimmune disorders maybe cancer or
have a high BMI they're all vulnerable
but thankfully the overwhelming majority
of people will tolerate this virus and
some have adaptive or innate immunity
and thus they won't even get sick or
sometimes even test positive when
they're exposed
now as for kids under the age of 18
where are they they basically have a 0%
chance of becoming seriously ill or
dying from this virus again unless
they're in one of those special
categories but pay no attention to
actual facts liberal school
superintendents and blue state governors
are of course opting toward keeping
schools closed as long as possible
I will not reopen our school system
August 24th if the conditions are what
they are today our reopening plan
contemplates a face to reality we are
still in phase 1a phase one that has
degraded
sense as over the past few weeks well
they talk about what is reckless like
opening is reckless
well stealing face-to-face education
that's reckless in miami-dade about 60%
of parents prefer the in-school model
30% say it's okay to go virtual now
siding with parents who see the enormous
long-term damage many children face
without regular in school instruction
president Trump sided with worried
mothers and fathers today we want to
reopen the schools
everybody wants it the moms want it the
dads want it the kids want it it's time
to do it we don't want people to make
political statements or do it for
political reasons they think it's going
to be good for them politically so they
keep the schools closed but rather than
focus on addressing the brain drain that
occurred last semester were hundreds of
thousands of kids in Virginia liberal
governor Ralph Northam is addressing
really really important issues in a
letter to the heads of school boards in
the state yesterday he says some names
and mascots have a quote traumatizing
impact on students families teachers and
staff traumatizing impact how about not
going to school for a traumatizing
impact Ralph empty gestures from the
guys still trying to recover from that
infamous costume party photo you bet now
in Virginia's liberal Fairfax County
left wing officials just announced that
parents would have two options in the
fall one they could go two days a week
in school for their kids or number two
four days a week a virtual instruction
okay two days in school or four days
virtual by the way there's zero ability
to switch once you've made the choice by
next week's deadline so what are parents
who work outside the home what are they
supposed to do we have always had
networks informally and now more than
ever we need our community to wrap
around family so I really hope that we
can have our communities of faith and
our nonprofits find ways to help support
these families in greater amounts than
we've ever done before
now that Scott Bray brand is a real
piece of work let's get this straight
it's too dangerous for kids to
congregate in class and learn and
interact with each other but it's okay
for them to congregate in church
basements what now as usual if you're
looking for culprits in the schools
regarding their lame biased curricula or
waffling on the question of reopening
the road always leads back to the
Democrats fiercest most loyal donors the
teachers unions Tina
Williams head of the Fairfax County
Federation of Teachers said we all want
kids back in school as quickly as
possible but that also means as safe as
possible okay well if that were the case
you wouldn't have send them to school
during what even Anthony foul she called
a terrible flu season for 2019 and 2020
then there's Kimberly Adams president of
the Fairfax Education Association
she says a vaccination or a widely
available treatment for Cova 19 is
necessary before a full return to
in-person instruction hey news flash
again Anthony foul she has to admit we
might not ever have a vaccine so should
kids just be kept out of school forever
this is ludicrous
tonight the vice president called the
union's out when we hear some word about
teachers unions beginning already to say
that they're not going to be willing to
come back in some jurisdictions around
the country look we all ought to be
working together on this
yeah well fat chance in New York we're
infections and hospitalizations are
declining Governor Andrew Cuomo still
has parents and students in total limbo
we have some time this is a very fluid
situation when we get the data we will
make a decision in the meantime I'm
telling all school districts to come up
with a reopening plan but we don't yet
know if we are going to reopen this is
this is unbelievable this is like child
abuse at some point from a medical and a
common-sense standpoint the decision to
put kids back in school should be a slam
dunk yes but since Joe Biden is bought
and paid for by the teachers unions he's
just going to rubber-stamp whatever they
decide a Biden campaign official tells
Fox News we need to ensure we can do it
safely in line with the recommendations
of public health experts translation the
unions want more money we need the money
for PPE we need the money for extra
teachers we need the money for extra
cleaning
extra buses but my members really want
to be with their kids they just want it
to be safe for both kids and for
themselves does anyone buy anything that
woman says is that all the taxpayers
will be funding by the way disinfectants
and cleaning crews and how do we know
that that money will really be enough
what if we spend all that money and the
teachers union insists on waiting for a
vaccine again the schools could be shut
down for years and that brings us back
to the big question are these schools
going to reopen at all in many
communities across the country at least
for now in Donald Trump we have a
president who's putting parents and
their children first but that could
change in November
a vote for Biden puts teachers unions
first and as a vote for more shutdowns
government edicts and controls and
that's the angle